so when you have a look at this what
does that indicate to you that we ought
to expect if we want to solve this
equation you need four equations okay
now thankfully for us we are not
actually trying to solve this equation
we're just trying to find out whether
there is a solution or not there is one
last piece of information that we
haven't written down there currency I'm
not going to do this because you know I
vow you not being poor but if I had this
right either
here's a piece of currency okay I if I
cut this in half one of each of the
heart worth they're worth nothing how
they right because you can't have half
and no it's like a it's like can you
break my five dollar sure okay let me
tell my businesses that doesn't work
it's not like 250 250 okay
so therefore what that implies that P Q
R and s are not just any numbers they
are a specific kind of number and you
have language for this right what kind
of numbers of it they're going to be
whole numbers integers is close but
they're not just integers because
integers can also be negative right at
least you'd hope that I don't have
negative negative five dollar notes if
like oh man I'm really really short
right so what I would say is here's my
third and final piece of information P Q
R and s I'm going to borrow some
notation from a previous lesson
they are integers remember that one that
are positive right so it's more than
just integers I'm a bit more specific
you this is it it's not for equations
but it's all I need you've got equation
one equation two now let's play okay
there's not much you can do with
equation one and two together right they
don't want to make any suggestions of
how I could put them together how I
could combine them simultaneously I can
combine them in a variety of ways I
could I could multiply than my things I
could add them what kind of operation do
you think would be most suitable to try
and simplify what's going on here
I think subtraction is the way to go
here's why when you have a look at just
regular simultaneous equations you'd
basically have two techniques at your
disposal does they not remember the two
techniques are one starts with an S one
starts with an E
you can solve by substitution what that
would mean is you would say do something
like this this is the equation 1 this is
equation 2 so this came from Equation 2
you'd take that and you'd substitute it
everywhere you saw a wide equation 1 you
did swap it ok what was the other method
elimination we use the elimination when
you've got you know things like this you
see how that possibly that when that Y
minus y they could care to that really
easily when you have a look at here do
you see why elimination and subtraction
is a sensible thing to do why is it yeah
you can eliminate this guy out of the
equation right so let's go ahead and do
that equation to take away equation 1p
will cancel so that leaves me with this
many Q's this many R's and this many S's
right so that's a good question this
comes back to what our PQRS I admit I
didn't write it so P Q R and s are how
many of each note do you have so for
example I might have a single thousand
dollar note so a thousand s would be a
thousand well I might have seventeen
thousand dollar notes in which case a
thousand s would be seventeen thousand
does that make sense so P Q R and s I'm
not the value of each though then the
quantity of each note does that make
correct yes it's the money back well
what that's equal to no s is not a
thousand s is any number I want it to be
it's how many how many of these thousand
dollar notes do I have if you had
exactly a thousand thousand dollars then
yes that would be a million but you
might have noticed thousand dollar notes
I don't have any thousand dollar notes
so that would be 0 times a thousand so
the point is S is a variable right it's
not a thousand it's how many thousands
do I have okay what am I going the right
time
1/2 million okay so what I do with this
is there anything obvious that screams
out at you that we could do that we'd
simplify this I can I can divide this
side all by nine can't I
there's five hundred thousand going
tonight what is nine going to fire it
doesn't does it
okay so watch what happens if you divide
by nine you get Q plus eleven R plus 111
s okay now if I remember correctly when
you divide this you're going to get I
think 55555 and five ninths of a dollar
someone can tell me if that's right or
not like I'm just trying to member and
just looking roughly you can see it's
going to be a rabbit right now this is
not much else you can do with this right
there's not many places to go don't
worry it's not going to look crazy
drippity I've done this problem okay
I've used this I've used this was a
final feature information that we talked
about the four they're all positive and
not just positive but positive integers
positive whole numbers okay do you see
that present a problem down here right
if each of these is a positive whole
number and you're multiplying each of
them by positive whole numbers there's
no way there's no combination of this
there's no - R or s that could give you
that guy that guy's the problem right I
didn't say it was wrong I just asked you
if he was sure which are very different
things okay
so how would I explain this right my
conclusion would be I would say but Q R
and s are positive integers right
therefore this thing over here Q plus 11
r plus 111 s that's also that's also a
positive integer
do you agree when you add these positive
integers together and multiply it by
more positive integers you only get
positive integers at the other end okay
five 55555 and five ninths is not it's
not a positive integer therefore there
are no solutions that make sense if you
see the way I logically constructed that